ya nos hemos familiarizado un poco más
con la idea de sumar y restar números
negativos lo que quiero hacer en este
vídeo es resolver varios ejemplos usando
la sección de ejercicios de la página de
khan academy de suma de números
negativos en rectas numéricas para que
podamos ver modelar o visualizar
diferentes formas de restar o sumar
números negativos o positivos nos
preguntan cuál recta numérica representa
la expresión menos dos quintos más
cuatro quintos vamos a ver cada una de
ellas en esta recta numérica vamos a
buscar menos dos quintos que es con el
que empezamos aquí está menos dos
quintos pero esta flecha no comienza
desde cero
esta flecha no me está representando el
menos dos quintos de hecho esta recta
numérica aquí tiene de cero a dos
quintos es dos quintos positivo más
cuatro quintos debería ser hacia la
derecha
y está hacia la izquierda esto
representa lo contrario esta recta no
médica tiene dos quintos menos cuatro
puntos así que esta no es la que nos
sirve veamos esta otra comienza con
menos cuatro quintos del cero al menos
cuatro quintos y nosotros estamos
buscando cuatro puntos positivos hacia
la derecha así que esta recta tampoco
nos sirve veamos esta representación
tenemos de 0 a menos dos quintos esta
flecha está bien y a partir de acá es
más cuatro puntos
veamos estoy aquí sumó un quinto dos
quintos tres quintos cuatro puntos justo
aquí cuando sumó cuatro quintos llego a
dos quintos está bien esta recta ésta es
la que me representa esta expresión
comprobamos respuesta
es correcta veamos otro ejemplo cuál
recta numérica representa la expresión
menos 1 un medio más un entero un medio
estás rectas son verticales pero es el
mismo principio vamos a partir desde
cero hacia arriba para las cantidades
positivas y hacia abajo para las
cantidades negativas esta recta que me
representa tengo aquí cero aquí tengo la
marca de un 3 así que esta será la marca
del 2 y está la marca del 1 entonces
tengo aquí hacia arriba un entero y la
mitad de un entero un medio tengo un
entero y un medio positivo y a esto esta
flecha hacia arriba me indica que a esto
le estoy sumando otro entero este de
aquí y otro medio que es esto un entero
y en medio positivos esto no es lo que
me están diciendo aquí aquí tengo menos
un entero un medio más
un entero un medio está no me sirve
veamos esta de 0 hacia abajo menos uno y
medio
tengo a partir de este un medio una
flecha hacia abajo me indica que estoy
restando va a ser una cantidad negativa
que va a ser un entero un medio hacia
abajo esta no me está expresando esto de
aquí vamos a ver esta última que yo
espero que sea así no va a haber un
error en el ejercicio tenemos esta
flechita que va del 0 hacia abajo y
recorre 1 y medio un entero un medio y
como es hacia abajo va a ser una
cantidad negativa menos un medio hasta
aquí esto sí está representado por esta
flecha y a partir de aquí tenemos una
flecha hacia arriba que indica que se
está sumando y se está sumando aquí
medio y un entero un entero y un medio
positivos llegamos al mismo cero esto
tiene lógica porque estoy recorriendo
hacia abajo la misma cantidad que voy a
recorrer hacia arriba así que llego al
mismo punto esta recta numérica si me
está representando esta expresión le
elegimos y comprobamos nuestra respuesta
es correcta veamos otro ejercicio cuál
recta numérica representa la expresión
menos dos tercios más menos un tercio
esto está interesante menos dos tercios
el menos indica que vamos a irnos hacia
la izquierda del cero entonces tenemos
aquí
ok cero tercios bueno sigue siendo cero
y hacia la izquierda tenemos menos un
tercio menos dos tercios aquí está bien
estamos llegando a esta cantidad y a
partir de aquí lo que nos dicen es que
se va a sumar una cantidad negativa es
decir esto nos dice que vamos a sumar
algo pero lo vamos a sumar hacia la
izquierda entonces aquí esta flechita
está hacia la derecha está sumando
cantidades positivas por lo que ésta no
nos está representando esta cantidad
bueno ésta no es veamos la de aquí abajo
de cero a menos dos tercios va bien aquí
tengo esta cantidad
y a partir de aquí sumo menos un tercio
menos un tercio es un tercio hacia la
izquierda que voy a recorrer a partir de
aquí recorro un tercio más hacia la
izquierda y me da menos tres tercios
esta es la opción correcta vamos a
comprobar la es correcto vamos a hacer
un ejercicio más cual recta numérica
representa la expresión 6 más menos 2
ahora nos tocaron números enteros
veamos estoy aquí desde cero y como ese
6 es un número positivo la flecha que lo
representa debe ir hacia arriba de 0 a 6
esta flecha lo representa bien y lo que
sigue es que a esto le agregamos 1 - 2
esté menos 2 es una cantidad negativa va
con la flechita hacia abajo dos lugares
y aquí vemos que esta flechita que parte
a partir de aquí son dos pero hacia
arriba son dos unidades positivas y no
es lo que nos están diciendo aquí esta
no es veamos esta otra voy de 0 a 6 la
flechita hacia arriba va muy bien y a
partir de aquí voy con la flechita hacia
abajo menos dos unidades aquí bajo una
aquí bajo dos unidades llegó a cuatro
esta recta numérica si está
representando esta expresión ya que
estoy con una cantidad positiva la
primera a la que le agrego una cantidad
negativa que va hacia abajo
esta es la correcta comprobamos la
respuesta y en efecto está bien